So, really, when we do relaxed consistency,
we allow a reordering of normal accesses
according to the four types of ordering. So, for example, our reads can now be
reordered, but only if these are normal
accesses. But then we add special non-reorderable
accesses. And the programmer must use these
non-reorderable accesses when ordering in the program matters.
An example of such non-reorderable accesses is the x86 MSYNC instruction. Here
in normal execution all accesses are reorderable. We cannot rely on any specific
in order behavior as far as consistency concerned, but no reordering can
happen across a MSYNC instruction. so we can have any axis that we want
reordered anywhere in here. But in problem order
then comes the MSYNC instruction. The process guarantees that
all of these are going to be done before we do MSYNC. And that the MSYNC will be
done before we begin the next cloud of
instructions that can again be ordered with each other.
So how does that help? It helps because
now we can write flag synchronization correctly. The correct
wait for a flag now includes an MSYNC instruction.
It basically says that, Wait for the flag to become
zero, make that happen and then use the data.
Now the processor will first make sure that the flag
is red, and only then that the data is
red. Because we cannot reorder the rates to the flag
and data cross them Msync. But it is still
allows all sorts of performance optimizations where we reorder instructions.
In situations where we are not trying
to use memory for synchronization like this.